bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
les commerçants et les agriculteurs ont
dû ruser d'ingéniosité pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire entre l'initiative
partenariat et renaissance nous les
avons rencontrés que nous sommes au
s'est rendu dans les locaux d'une
entreprise élan courtoise afin qu'elle
nous explique son retour à l'activité de
son côté et l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise oeuvre depuis le 16
mars pour soutenir les professionnels
nous ferons le point sur les aides mises
en place comment se porte le commerce à
saint quentin en yvelines ont fait deux
tours c'est parti
[Musique]
devant la médiathèque à montigny le
bretonneux
les sportifs se réunissent sous la
houlette du coach julien lechevallier
avec le confinement c'est j'ai commencé
à mettre des en place des cours
collectifs au niveau de l'université de
saint quentin
comme c'est un petit peu vide avec les
magasins fermés dans le centre pour
qu'un peu plus de vie y est proposé de
faire un cours en plus juste derrière la
médiathèque il c'est son ami damien
coach gérant de resto cocorico avec
lequel il a créé un partenariat chaque
mercredi à 18 heures c'est une séance de
sport et puis récompensé tous les
sportifs avec un apéro ça mettait un peu
de gaieté dans cette période un peu un
peu difficile durant le confinement pour
survivre les commerçants ont dû innover
en plus de ce partenariat sportif damien
coach à repenser sa carte et à proposer
des produits à emporter qu'on a fait
notre choix sur sur les burger
ce sont des plats qu'on retrouve à la
carte du restaurant habituellement donc
avec la même qualité de produits des
produits français des pains fabriqués
par le boulanger du coin on a dû revoir
tous nos approvisionnements pour
signaler son redémarrage
le restaurateur réinvente son site
internet et communiquent sur les réseaux
sociaux
il ya un groupe qui s'appelle tu viens
de montigny qui est qui et sur facebook
et puis il ya aussi le groupe sky
commerçants il ya eu vraiment une
monter des commandes au fur et à mesure
continue plaisir villepreux resto
cocorico livres à domicile mais pas
seulement
on a livré des plateaux repas pour les
ehpad ont livré des plateaux repas pour
les pompiers le centre qu'ovide de
montigné les médecins voient là et tout
ça était financée par une cagnotte
participative et on a vraiment été ravis
du soutien qu'ils nous ont apporté des
gens que les les clients vraiment été
vraiment été réceptifs à nos
communications
dès le 2 juin resto cocorico a rouvert
sa terrasse petit à petit les clients
sont revenus
[Musique]
là c'est plus classique c'est ce qu'on
appelle pour me parler
nicolas est le wild à guyancourt a connu
un parcours similaire jeu restrictif en
confinement à la maison
faisait un peu les méninges et puis je
me suis dit faut absolument faire
quelque chose on va livrer essayer de
livrer sur la zone de lui en posant les
gourmands une initiative payante
les petits déjeuners avec boissons et
croissants chauds livrés à domicile se
sont multipliés comme des petits pains
ça nous a permis de nous faire connaître
dans le coin et ce qui est une bonne
surprise c'est que les gens demander
vraiment ce genre de produits de
services
la boutique a aussi livré des produits
du quotidien farine levure peu et des
miches de pain réalisé avec de la farine
bio des yvelines et ça a charmé les
bureaux courtois et les habitants de 50
ans qui ont commandé échangées sur les
réseaux sociaux et mixa a tissé un peu
une toile d'araignée ca fait boule de
neige et donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec de plus en plus de filles en chaque
semaine c'est le site ce qui soutient
ces commerçants
en fait c'est simple tous les samedis
dimanches c'est presque comme si c'était
notre facebook à nous parce qu'en fait
les gens communiquent et partage
énormément leurs coups de coeur
ça a été vraiment un énorme un énorme
coup d'accélérateur désormais gâteau
reçoit en boutique et pour la fête des
mères 60% de commandes supplémentaires
dans l'atelier les produits sont conçus
devant les clients pâtisserie à partager
macarons chocolats et autres d'un gris
sont proposées du vendredi au dimanche
avec une nouvelle carte chaque semaine
surprise garantie
les entreprises et les agriculteurs
n'ont pas échappé aux difficultés durant
le confinement certains sont partis à la
recherche d'un autre public
d'autres ou anticiper la reprise
[Musique]
pierre-jean là là où ray producteurs de
fruits et légumes de saison distribue
ses produits depuis dix ans en gare de
la verrière de plaisir de réunion et de
saint quentin en yvelines en partenariat
avec la sncf
le seroc du jour au lendemain tout s'est
arrêté là commercialisons s'est arrêté
la fréquentation des gars a diminué et
c'est vrai que sur le coup ça a été
booth a été pénalisé l'association
coignières en transition a eu l'idée de
créer des actions de solidarité d'une
d'elles aider les petits producteurs
le but vendre directement au
consommateur
dès la première distribution quarante
sept paniers ont été commandés l'idée
c'est vraiment de faire un drive
maraîchers ou les personnes passent
commande et elles viennent chercher leur
commande sur le à la gare et paye et
près de leur panier elles s'en vont
chaque lundi les clients passent
commande en ligne pour réceptionner
leurs paniers deux jours plus tard entre
18 et 20 heures
tomates asperges betteraves carottes
pommes de terre mais aussi ciboulette
oignons pain et des fruits frais fraises
pommes poires rhubarbe ou encore jus de
fruits en six semaines de distribution
305 paniers ont été commandés par plus
de 120 familles ce qui a surtout fait
boule de neige c'est la confusion sur
les réseaux sociaux sur facebook donc là
les réseaux sociaux de coignières de
maurepas de saint quentin
le groupe de saint quentin qui aide les
commerçants
voilà et c'est comme ça que des
personnes ont entendu parler
ça a été relayée d'autres associations
dans les autres villages alentour ont
relayé la mayonnaise a pris
ça a aidé les chocolateries ça a été les
jardineries ça a aidé les animaleries
aider tous les commerçants qui avaient
besoin d' aide à ce moment là et qu'ils
avaient besoin de se faire connaître de
trouver de nouveaux clients parce qu'ils
en avaient perdu par ailleurs une
difficulté identique pour les petites
entreprises
personne n'était préparé devoir
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain être
enfermé chez soi devant arrêter une
entreprise stopper une entreprise
pourtant le 11 mai il a bien fallu
redémarrer
il a fallu anticiper déjà cette date
c'était prendre contact avec des
fournisseurs pour trouver des masques du
gel des visières de protection bigand
prendre contact avec les clients leur
envoyer des mails à partir de la semaine
avant le 11 avec un dossier spécifique
pour le coc vide et être assurés que les
fournisseurs puissent niveau m pour
signaler sa réouverture tout est bon
porte-à-porte page facebook de
l'entreprise
méline mais aussi aide de ses
fournisseurs et puis bien on s'est fait
connaître sur la page que de l'agglo de
saint quentin
c'est une excellente initiative de 50
ans a pris vis-à-vis des commerces les
commerçants de proximité
je n'ai pas vu ça ailleurs on m'a dit on
va quand même faire savoir via cette
page que tu as bêta est à nouveau
disponible
jean-philippe le quéré poste donc un
message en l'espace de quelques heures
on a été étonné de voir plus de 700 vue
donc sur cette page facebook qui est
donc suivi ce temps que ça fonctionne et
que les besoins existent
les gens sont restés confinés nous est
de rester chez soi on voit tout ce qui
va pas et on se dit pas tout compte fait
ça fait incitatif prenons contact doit
et qu'on est sur des différents réseaux
sociaux et contactez nous pour avoir des
devis nous avons énormément de demandes
[Musique]
certes le site facebook dédiée aux
commerçants et aux agriculteurs et créé
par l'agglomération a permis à tous de
se signaler et aux habitants de trouver
à se ravitailler au plus près de leur
domicile
mais le territoire a mis en place une
multitude d'actions pour les
professionnels nous avons fait le point
avec valérie a fallu on avait un plan
d'action rapidement qui se déclinait sur
déjà un premier chapitre d'information
de deux prêts conseil auprès des
commerçants impactés
on a également mis en place un plan
d'action en termes d'appuis financiers
en complément du fonds résidences de la
région ile de france després initiative
portée par saint quentin en yvelines des
exonérations de loyer pour les
commerçants de charge est également
troisième chapitre qu'on a mis en place
tout un dispositif de promotion de
communication pour pour nos commerçants
et donc avec une cartographie
interactive des actions de communication
des campagnes d'affichage est également
donc la création très rapidement de ce
groupe facebook qui était destiné à
l'ensemble de nos commerçants artisans
prestataires de services à la personne
les agriculteurs s'ils sont s'y sont
greffés également et qui ont vraiment
pris cet outil comme le leur et c'était
ça l'objectif en vérité ces commerçants
se sentait un petit peu démuni en termes
d'outils de communication ils n'ont pas
tous ses moyens de faire des campagnes
d'affichage
le distribuer c'était en plus difficile
pendant la période du kobe de scribes et
des flyers etc
donc on a on a trouvé cette est l'outil
déjà le plus rapide à mettre en place le
plus interactif peut-être c'est un outil
qui nous paraissait le plus pertinent
ce à impulser une très forte dynamique
et cette dynamique peut-être un
phénomène auquel on s'était peut-être
pas attendu c'est également
l'utilisation par les consommateurs par
les clients eux mêmes qui nous ont
déclaré par exemple pour plus de 90%
d'entre eux dira avoir découvert voir
redécouvert des commerçants qui ne me
connaissaient pas aujourd'hui la
cartographie interactive compte près de
600 commerçants référence et le site
facebook plus de 3900 inscrits durant le
confinement le territoire a également
mis en place un système de boue d'achat
que les consommateurs pourraient
utiliser dans leur commerce pour un
service ultérieure chez leur coiffeur
libraires ou kalliste alors en termes de
santé
et d'impact on en a quand même plus de
la moitié qui se débat qui se déclarent
impacter fortement par contre qu'on peut
constater c'est qu'actuellement on est
dans une bulle c'est à dire qu'on a
peut-être moins de clients qui
fréquentent laisser les pôles
commerciaux
mais pour le moment on a parfois un
constat et c'est notamment dans les
grands pôles commerciaux d'un
accroissement malgré tout du chiffre
d'affaires c'est à dire que les gens
viennent moi mais consomme plus il ya un
retard à rattraper un retard du moins le
11 juin saint quentin en yvelines a voté
un plan de relance économique de 2
millions d'euros pour les petites
entreprises dont 500000 euros de
participation au fonds résilience porté
par la région
une avance remboursable sur six ans
[Musique]
depuis le 2 juin et la rouverture
progressive des restaurants par les
terrasses une autre organisation s'est
dessinée au resto cocorico les équipes
ont été rappelés la terrasse est agrandi
un qr code permet de consulter la carte
en ligne
le concept sport apéro lui perdu en
battue peu une vie sociale qui se met en
place
les gens sont super contents de se
revoir aussi parce que le cadre est
super agréable et puis amis on se
retrouvait après derrière autour d'un
jardin d'hiver avec ou sans alcool au
sein de l'atelier gâteau de guyancourt
des cours de master class de pâtisserie
devrait être impulsé dès septembre avec
davantage de jours d'ouverture en
semaine à la boutique aujourd'hui une
question de fermer les paniers de fruits
et légumes frais se poursuivent en gare
de coignières sur la cloche la clientèle
francilienne commencent à se rendre
compte qu'il faut manger local et
évitez les grands transport éviter
d'aller acheter au bout du monde ou ou
si le produit bien sûr les produits qui
sont produits dans la région autant les
consomme la région tant qu'il ya de la
demande aussi bien du côté de monsieur
là la vrai que du côté des personnes qui
sont demandeuses
on continue quoi afin de répondre aux
nouvelles commandes mais aussi pour
pallier au report des interventions
prévues avant le confinement
fb concept ne fermera pas en août
on a énormément de demandes donc ça fait
énormément de devis en cours et donc on
a un carnet de commandes qui s'étend
maintenant bientôt jusqu'à l'en tête
automne
[Musique]
ce qui m'agace c'est fini n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez continuer de vous
inscrire sur le site facebook dédiée aux
commerçants et aux producteurs que vous
soyez professionnel ou consommateurs à
très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]